best known for playing Tommy Oliver in
the Power Rangers franchise actor and
mixed martial artist Jason David Frank
died at the age of 49 on November 19th
as of the making of this video the cause
of his death has not been made public
even though Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
only aired for three seasons back in the
90s Frank stayed connected to the Power
Rangers franchise while some might write
the series off as a silly show for kids
many episodes explored important themes
like friendship and responsibility the
simplistic character designs were an
easy way to capture a child's
imagination while delivering some
valuable life lessons Frank played Tommy
Oliver aka the Green Ranger as recently
as 2018 and he continued to demonstrate
his pride in the franchise on social
media the character was initially
introduced as a short-term antagonist
but Frank's Dynamic performance and
extensive martial arts training helped
him carve out a permanent place for the
character if you're a fan of Frank's
work then you'll be glad to know that
his final project pays homage to the
years he spent as the Green Ranger from
the looks of it legend of the white
dragon dragon is a blend of fantasy
science fiction and dystopian action
thriller the crowdfunded film began as a
Kickstarter campaign in March 2020
reaching its 500 000 goal only a few
months later in July 2021 Frank told
comicbook.com that a private investor
took over from there but the film's
future is unclear according to the
campaign website the film is currently
in post-production with no hard release
date set joining Frank in the cast is
Jason font from Power Rangers Time Force
and Sierra Hannah Power Rangers
Megaforce according to the movie's
website the plot follows a humbled
Warrior returning home after being
defeated in battle Frank plays Eric Reid
known as the white dragon before his
power source was destroyed during combat
without access to the full breadth of
his powers and shunned by the people he
wasn't strong enough to protect Reed is
determined to defeat the evil wreaking
havoc on his home however he'll need
more than luck to regain his powers and
avenge his name while the premise of the
PG-13 film has a somewhat darker tone
than Frank's past work Eric Reid's
backstory is reminiscent of Tommy
Oliver's storyline in Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers viewers will recall that
the Green Ranger found Redemption as the
White Ranger after being freed from Rita
repulsa's mind control
is it really you in the flesh
despite the otherworldly setting the
lesson at the heart of the story is
based in reality similar to how Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers used Fantastical
story lines to help make the
heartwarming morals pack a punch the
minds behind legend of the white dragon
used the same tactic when crafting the
plot of the film according to Frank
feelings like isolation and regret
inspired his character's emotional
Journey even though Reed is a character
with Incredible Powers he has his
problems just like everyone else Frank
told comicbook.com back in 2021 a lot of
teens or kids deal with depression
especially during this quarantine stuff
no one really thinks about the
depression aspect of it so I feel that
they can relate to more realistic life
meaning that we all have problems that
we deal with you're going to see that in
Eric Reid Frank was promoting legend of
the white dragon in the months leading
up to his death including showing off
the character's helmet and a fan tattoo
on his Instagram it's unclear when the
film will come out though vulture
reports it is currently expected to
release sometime in 2023
foreign
[Music]